- I'm gonna win,
and I'm gonna be smiling the whole time cuz I beat your son.
- That is funny. That's a joke.
You beat my son, I will come up and
shake your hand and congratulate you.
That's not gonna happen, Chuck.
- Hey, Google, start a group call.
- Hey, guys, what's up?
Yo, man.
Are you cooking a turkey?
It better not be dry.
- This turkey's gonna be nice.
Never messed one up yet.
- What's going on, Chuck?
Hey, I don't think any last-minute practice
is gonna help you right now.
- Thanks.
What can I do to get under Steph's skin?
- Right before he's about to putt,
just ask him, "Hey, is my mark OK?"
If it's a little closer, that might get in his head
and put a little bit of extra pressure on him.
- I'm not sure that'll be an option for you, Chuck.
You know, your ball has to be closer to the hole
in order to mark it first.
- Dell, be nice.
I don't wanna bring up my stats against you.
- This is not the '90s. And I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say
I'm in a little better shape than you,
so we can take it to the court next time I see you.
- Hey, this is a different game now, Chuck.
We shootin' three-ball; you was all in
the paint.
You gotta bring it out and extend that range
these days, my guy.
- I'm not even gonna dignify that with a response.
I'm gonna win—
and you're gonna have to come and walk up to me and
shake my hand and say congratulations.
- [Laughing] That is funny.
I've seen both of you play.
You have no shot.
- Let's make a bet.
If I hit it on the green on the 19th hole,
you take me to your club for the buffet.
- The 19th hole—isn't that an island green?
You hit the green, I'll take you to my club.
I'm buying the buffet dinner.
- Bet.
- The buffet.
I just saw your eyes light up when you said that.
- Hey, man, have a good time.
- Goodbye. And save me some of that dry turkey.
- Bye, Chuck.
- If I can get 'em like that, I'll be all right.